let's talk about dialogue you tell the
characters what to say or are you almost
hearing them tell you it's a good
question you know I think in dialogue
they kind of say that you can't really
teach somebody how to write dialogue you
can't do somebody had it you can show
somebody how to write more tightly or
more naturally but basically dialogue is
something that you know you need to have
a feel for you don't I mean it's a heart
it's not like teaching structure or
something like that
and I think I think it's a combination
of the two things you said I think your
characters speaking to you
hopefully you created a unique enough
character or a character within with a
strong enough sense of who they are or
what they're you know how you would
describe that character and what their
journey is going to be emotional journey
is going to be that the words kind of
they kind of they don't write themselves
necessarily but they but but it's it's
like the track that the train is running
on so so you know you you know what the
characters about you know where they're
gonna go you know what they're doing
right you know what they're doing wrong
and and and what you want them to be and
how they talk needs to match that basis
of who they are you know if that's clear
so that so there's that you find that
when you start writing dialogues
sometimes the characters talk
differently than you then you expect
that evolves you know and that and that
can be very interesting and sometimes
your character changes as a result of
your dialogue but by and large you know
that you know it's we're using our
voices we're using voices of people we
know we're using Cadence's we're using
regional you know words you know it's
it's a combination of a lot of things
but it does in a way it does write
itself you know you're the you're the
driver but you know it does kind of roll
out but again a dialogue you know it's
about how do you write natural dialogue
how do you how do you write the way
people really speak and it's cadence and
it's it's it's simplicity of words it's
it's you know expressing saying the most
amount the most amount of ideas and the
least amount of letters basically at
least amount of words and to keep it all
moving forward so it's it's hard I think
you kind of be there right good dialogue
I think it's a tough one well for your
stage plays is rehearsal really the only
place that you can kind of try out to
see if that dialog for the character
works the parcels are critical where
right now where we're reading through
the play we might directors dividing the
play into beads and sections and and
we're really focusing on yeah after
we've read through it all together now
we're focusing on the individual words
and to see exactly what's working and
you know what what words really don't
quite make sense so what what I have in
my mind that the actresses aren't
necessarily feeling or getting or they
don't quite know how to say it or the
director isn't sure and that's an
amazing process you know it's like a
fantastic process so being able to hone
the words it's kind of rare you know do
just it just doing a table read of your
script before something is produced
which doesn't always happen is really
really helpful you have to hear other
voices of the ones in your head you know
you have to hear them say the words so
it sounds like four scripts then you
wouldn't always get a chance you might
just get notes back right you get you
get a lot of notes back but it's but if
you you know you know you unless you on
your own before you turn in a script
have you know gather some actors and and
you know try to try to test it out you
can do that but by and large you write a
script you turn it in you get notes
they'll and then then the notes come
with dialogue issues I don't understand
this line
this isn't funnier love that line this
works this doesn't you know could you
add a little bit put a little twist on
it that's duplicated you know that kind
of thing but which is very helpful and
it's all like I look at the scripts it's
just this big piece of clay that you
know you're constantly molding and
shaping and you know it's just sort of
moving with and trying to find the shape
to it and until you have your you know
the piece of pottery that you're trying
to make you know it's it's a lot a lot
of changes you know they always say they
say the writing is rewriting you know
and that's really you know and that's so
important you know I'm a big believer in
rewriting I'm fine about rewriting as
long as it makes sense and it's not just
to do it to because you do make things
better you can't get it on one fell
swoop at least I can you know you you
have to write and rewrite and sort of
really work on it and let think about it
and get some distance from the material
to you know so that you can sort of look
at it with your own fresh eyes and you
have a much better sense of what works
and what doesn't work I find some of the
most interesting dialogue just being in
LA and hearing to people for maybe like
less than a minute right you can take so
much from that you ever do that okay you
can build a whole hearing things writing
things down writing down expressions
like oh my god what a great expression
what does that mean I'm gonna take that
you know or it just the dynamic between
people you know kind of kinds of
relationships who's talking to who at
the supermarket listening to a couple
arguing or or being too nice to each
other or whatever it is you know it's
fascinating I'm always writing things
down yeah so in terms of being a writer
and wanting to add that dialogue how
much are you paying attention to seeing
a couple in a restaurant let's say and
maybe little is being said and you can
tell there's like some tension or sorry
well you know a lot is said with that
being said at all there's always that
you know and subtext is very important
in your writing so you're not just you
know you're not just you you know it's
not just the dialogue has like some
depth to it and and what your exact what
they're saying is not necessarily what
they mean you know they're saying a to
really mean B because they're there
their intention to see you know there's
that so there are different layers to
the to the dialogue and sometimes
honestly you don't know know about that
until you write it and until you look
back on it and say wow that was kind of
interesting or like that speech didn't
really go in the direction I thought it
would and yet it's kind of an
interesting twist you know but you just
try to make it real you try to make it
the way real people interact in real
situations if it's that kind of
certainly does that kind of moving so
you recommend that to other writers in
terms of getting enriching dialogue yes
pay attention pay attention the world
around you and you know I something I
watch I'll watch the movie or something
on TV or whatever and and I'll look at
like the the run of dial of speak Manama
a phenomenal speech you know and it by
you know phenomenal piece of diet you
know I loved the newsroom there and so I
can show the HBO show and and you know I
would literally just like just look at
it just play back over and over though
certain sections of that show and the
way that dial
was constructed and you know he's such a
genius in terms of constructing dialogue
and the word that he has as people use
but you can learn so much from that you
can be so inspired and and then put your
own voice into that kind of thing and
again a lot of a lot of writing dialogue
is cadence and and personality and and
things like that and trying to have
characters sound different you know so
that not every character sounds exactly
the same you know you give every
character their own voice which is
tricky it's hard to do but but that's
that's also really important and you
have to create a little bit of you have
to create character you know beneath you
know character that that's kind of
driving that dialogue for that even if
it's just the you know a supporting
character somebody we don't see very
much but yeah you can you got to pay
attention to what's around you it's you
know the best things are out of reality
also - what about writing for a specific
time period I mean you would take let's
say two men in the 40s in a newsroom
we're going to speak it probably much
more of an eloquent fashion versus sort
of the bro culture of today which is or
dude you know yeah yeah it's very very
different very different it look people
in the 70s and 80s talk differently in
the 90s and the lows you know I mean
it's it's over the 40s 50s it's all very
different but the basic community of
communicating you know having clear
interesting words that lead you to a
particular point that's always what you
know it is it's how you get there it's
been a little bit different and writing
anything I've written that's had a
interest like I wrote a Christmas movie
for homework few years ago and and there
were flashbacks to the 1920s and I had a
write dialogue that was seemed about
right for the 1920s and it was just
cadence you know it was just being a
little bit more formal you know a little
bit more on the nose maybe with some of
the things that were said and it was
fine you know and it just I think it
worked you know I mean it wasn't about
using it using going back and say now
what word did they use in the 1920s for
you know automobile you know was
something I mean it wasn't that it was
just it was a feeling it was a texture
to the words so that can be really fun
you know because we don't know exactly
know how people talked I mean yes we
have movies from back then and we can
see but we're still filtering those
things through it working
temporary perspective so it's not gonna
be quite like it was back then and you
want people to be able to relate to it
and understand it
you